ellos
un estallido de carcajadas o luego de
que un solo voto fuera para otro miembro
de su propio partido fuera de eso hubo
pocas sorpresas yo sí he de suba fue
electo el 99º primer ministro de japón
por una abrumadora mayoría con el
principal líder opositor mucho más atrás
el hombre de 71 años es el primer
mandatario distinto a xinzo ave en casi
8 años pero pocos esperan algo más que
un simple cambio de cara
no pienso que las cosas vayan a ser
mucho peor ni mucho mejor poco cambiar a
un iphone espero que el nuevo gobierno
supere la crisis que el coronavirus y
realice los juegos olímpicos sin grandes
cambios en sus políticas jugar ganó el
liderazgo del partido gobernante bajo la
promesa de estabilidad y continuidad y
hereda un país en una profunda recesión
el pib de japón se hundió casi un 8% en
el segundo cuarto de este año por la
pandemia de coronavirus la política de
expansión monetaria denominada avn o
mick no logró fortalecer
fundamentalmente la economía
en política exterior se espera que suba
continúe priorizando las radiaciones de
japón con eeuu luego de que el gobierno
anterior allanar el camino para que las
fuerzas de autodefensa japonesas puedan
luchar en el extranjero para defender a
un aliado mientras que temas como la
disputa territorial con rusia seguirían
estancados
la política exterior básica de japón se
basará en el fortalecimiento de la
alianza de seguridad con eeuu japón
intentará no dañar sus relaciones con
china tanto como pueda pero no rehuirá
de balancearse contra china dalián
xingang einstein con 11 de los 20
ministros del gabinete anterior y el
hermano menor de ave como nuevo ministro
de defensa el gobierno de sudán es
largamente visto como más de lo mismo